Ooh before this video begins, however,
we have a special offer announcement from Origin PC *cheering sound effect*
They're running a December only special,
with offers that include: free upgrade up to a two terabyte Seagate SSHD for PC
Bonus digital games
Bonus digital games, and more. Check out Nvidia Geforce r-tx GPUs on Origin PC desktops. Ooh
Where you can experience certain pieces of games with lifelike lighting, shadows, and reflections.
And if you get one of these r-tx GPUs
You also get a free copy of Battlefield 5 so you can see the ray-tracing technology firsthand on your PC
Ok, that's epic.
Also guys, don't forget about the NEURON giveaway that's going on.
If you haven't signed up that yet,
I mean what the frick are you doing? You get the same computer that I have? It's amazing.
I seriously love this thing.
It's got all the same specs as me as well,
And it's built with Origin PCs exclusive case
Which is really cool. You can tell the difference as well. And you can even customize your own designs on these case
You can tell the difference as well.
And you can even customize your own designs on these cases
It's really cool.
I know you want one. What are you doing? Go over to Origin PC and smash a like on this video
Right. Fricking. Now.
The link to the content is in description. Now, let's keep watching the video
What is TikTok and is it safe? Hello fellow parents I'm here to address your concerns
My name is PewDiePie, and you can trust me.
Y̵̡̘͘o̷̙̬̓ủ̸͇r̴̼̉ ̷̛͔k̸̪̳̔̌í̷̝͈d̸̦̰͛͑s̶͓͇͠ ̷̫̿̏a̷͕̬͆̎ṟ̶̓e̸͍̻̿ ̴̘͒͌s̶̢͎̕͠a̶̲͌ͅf̶̱̮̀͝ë̵̠́͜ ̸̟̾͠ẉ̸́ì̸͕͖t̷͈̺͒h̸̦̊͜ ̵̝̩̄m̶̖̌e̶̺͑́.̴̝́͌
Now, Tik Tok...
Why are my kids miming to copyrighted material?
I don't know
(Laughs)
But I think we can all agree on is that Tik Tok has a Nazi problem? That's right everybody.
Tik Tok which is mega popular with children has a problem with blatant violent white su--
WHERE?!
Any mainstream media are trying to write an article?
Oh, that's really interesting. Oh this new thing is getting popular
How can we draw the connection with Nazism?
So I'm here, of course, to address these concerns for fellow parents to make sure that your childs are safe
I also have this TV in the background now. I don't know for some reason I thought
"Hey, that's a good idea."
Why not had copyrighted material in the background that will make my life easier!
But ev- without further ado...
Let's just jump into it.
Okay, "my love and affection."
Gee, I wonder where he's gonna throw it?
Kppft--
[God damnit...]
That was a only funny 'cause of that dad's face.
(Clap x3)
(Clap x4)
That's someone getting love and affection right there.
See this is what I'm telling you parents:
Tik Tok is completely safe!
There's nothing to worry about
Look at this!
Just love and affection being spread everywhere.
Makes me happy.
Oh God, you know, you know kids are gonna start doing this through their parents now.
It's literally one Tik Tok gets famous and everyone copies it.
What is Tik Tok, and why does my son keep throwing tortillas at my face?
Mom, you didn't do the right reaction!
(Laughs)
You're supposed to be in pain!
(Laughs Again)
All right, let's keep jumping into it guys.
What is this?
Oh- my god.
(Inaudible Laughter)
We're gonna have to cut this video guys.
See, this is what I'm talking about!
It's so nice with talented young artists on tik tok.
Finally getting recognition!
Makes me happy.
It makes me warm.
It makes me--
I can't even- no, no, I refuse.
Hey guys. It's my first day living in the hood.
Sup, yo, it's my first week living in hood.
Aight been in this bitch for about a month now.
Fuck you mean dick.
We've been in this bitch for about two months now
Sup, bitch?
(Laughs)
This is me, one week in Sweden.
This is me, two weeks in Sweden!
SCAKJNFKSNKJN!! (Swedish word I won't even try to spell)
That actually hurt my throat. Jesus.
Sorry, neighbors.
Oh, is he gonna do it?
Ooh, damn that was sexy. That's some sexy quality. Oh!
:OOOO
DAMN!
That's impossible... A trinity?
Wow!
I thought it was real, because at the at this one...
It bounces off the top.
Right?
'Cause I've seen ones that cheat, and they...
Why do I care? You know what it doesn't matter.
Hey proud to say that I'm a granddaughter of a world war two vet as well as the neice of a correctional officer
however people on this app pretending to be like whatever military branch or
Special Forces or FBI or whatever have to knock it off
This is why the United States is screwed everybody cuz everyone be doing Fortnite dances
Okay, this is one of those
Okay, what's it gonna be?
I mean no. Oh god. Damn. It. Never mind. Actually. This does not help the case at all that I was trying to make
Okay, it's a twin
That's kind of cool I guess see it's just people having fun guys there's no Nazi joke- *laughs*
TikTok Rewind 2018, okay
Hahaha no, no no no no, no
Close if you're white if you're black if you're trans, if you're gay if you're lesbian, it's okay
Cuz everybody has something in common and what we have in common
We don't think Lele Pons is funny. She that's right everybody
That's right everybody, but she's still in rewind
Still in rewind top ten scientists still can't figure it it out and I used to spend so much time
like focus and thinking about him and not me the minute that I stopped and I was like, you know
I don't need a guy. That's when I peaked in my career
Her career peaked everybody.Who- at this point-
Who's doing TikToks unironically because we all have ironic TikToks and then reacting to ironic TikToks
But I feel like at some point it's gonna be unironic ironic TikToks really reacting to I wrote you know
I that's already happening, who am I kidding-
Who's it gonna be who's it gonna be?
I'd like this and I swear I don't even remember watching it. What's wrong with me?
HIT OR MISS I GUESS THEY NEVER MISS HUH
YOU GOTTA BOYFRIEND I BET HE DOESN'T KISS YA BLEHH
HE GON' FIND ANOTHER GIRL AN' HE WON'T MISS YA
HE GON' SKRT THEN HIT THE DAB LIKE WHIZ KHALIFA
I'm so disappointed in myself ahahah.
Well good thing this isn't ya life, you lose Look at my health bar. It's completely fine!
It's fine. I'm doing fine. By the way you guys I'm doing great.
So people have really been calling me homophobic
So listen, this is my house right here. I am opening the door and walking in this bitch
All right. So if I'm homophobic then why the hell would I walk into my home yo, yo
You can't argue with facts and logic
You cannot argue with facts and logic
goddamn
Hey, it's her again
I mean I sorta got at this point you're better off making an ironic tick-tock but secretly ironic
Cuz you know everyone's gonna take that bait, you know, if you open yourself up to get bullied
Everyone's gonna do it and you'll get TikTok famous for all the wrong reasons
For more content like this - Subscribe to "T Series"
I think TikTok is one of the famous things that happened this year unironically, you know
When you first saw it you were like goddammit
Not another thing like I cannot have another thing like this in 2018 blessing in disguise everybody blessing in disguise
Let's end that episode there. Wow. There was a lot of fun. I think we proved our point today
That TikTok is a Nazi and that's really the main point of this video. Hope you guys enjoyed. Smash the like if you enjoyed and
Make sure that you enjoyed and everyone tweet this video to James Charles and he's just gonna be like what the f dude?
Can you imagine James Charles reaction, like watching this?
Oh my god. I'm freaking out. You want pyramids? We got him!
Oh, you're into castles, huh? We got you covered baby. You want some bets easy?
We got it all
This game is still relevant. God damn it!